do not ask me why because I won't have
an answer for you I won't have a good
answer anyway in a world where hundreds
of movies all the film that comes out in
the course of a year I do videos on a
fraction of them today I'm doing a video
on this I I gotta admit though with the
trailer came out I was like that looks
awful
I have to
[Music]
so the monsters is written and directed
by Rob Zombie who's usually known for
his horror Gore Fest he has his
dedicated fan base no doubt but
generally speaking people seem to agree
that his horror movies are passable
in the way your dogs bark when you're
filming and that I have a lot of friends
over and we got chips and popcorn and
drinks and it's the month of October
we're gonna watch some Horror oh Rob
Zombie film right and it seems Rob
Zombie so loves the monsters that he was
like I'm gonna make a rated PG family
comedy
it's unexpected now the trailer was
terrible I don't know how else to say it
the movie lived up to the trailer but
the trailer did the film no favors okay
but it seems the world heard the cries
of the internet thus this Rob Zombie
Monsters movie was dumped on Netflix
Financial calls like this are are why
people question Netflix maybe they were
banking on that morbid curiosity factor
which admittedly got me I mean here I am
I watched it and I'm doing a video on it
optimistically I will say there is
potential in the world of this monster's
movie they all live in Transylvania
which kind of reminds me of the
Beetlejuice cartoon you're gonna hear
the premise and then maybe you can just
take that information and allocate it to
whatever entertainment you watched that
wasn't the Beetlejuice animation you're
not as old as I am possibly but you know
that ghoulishly endearing world it's a
whole Monster World they have their
economy then they step into our world
and they find our world as weird and
scary as we find them the movie is
essentially three films in one you have
your romantic comedy of Herman Munster
and Lily getting together then there's a
real estate scam then they buy a house
in the real world there's a lot going on
in this movie like far more than you
would think and I don't think it's going
to entertain children as much as Rob
Zombie probably wants it to which is
funny because Grandpa Munster which I
guess his father-in-law monster because
not all the monsters are here it being a
prequel backstory reimagining Eddie
Munster and Marilyn Munster they're not
here it's just these three monsters
hanging out but he keeps banging on bad
comedy in this movie and I I couldn't
help but think that's either
unironically an amazingly self-aware
series of moments or ironically the
movie's just not self-aware at all the
movie has a color palette that could be
fun for kids but the camera works just
nauseating it does that Rob Zombie Thing
where it's zooming in and out and
twisting and turning you could talk
about how it represents the off-world
off mindset of the monsters like they're
from a different plane of existence but
it was also annoying in execution that's
the thing about this movie there are a
lot of Concepts I'm like I get what you
were going for
but it did not work for this there's a
camp and cheese factor in this movie
that you can tell is a conscious effort
to throw back to the camp and cheese
factor of a sitcom from the 1960s it's
like a state through my dead glass
what an execution This Love Letter fell
flat I mean Rob Zombie wrote the movie
my first thought was well
is he a good comedic writer I know it's
a lot of dad jokes and puns there's some
play on a situation that I appreciated
but again you have to execute it with
better comedic timing a lot of it came
across as an unfunny SNL sketch or a
modern SNL sketch take your pick the two
are the same and that comes down to one
the writing to the directing and three
the casting I get that Rob Zombie's kind
of found his crew he likes to work with
I don't mean to single out Sherry Moon
Zombie and it's not for the sake of
being a dick what I'm saying is this
film required a lot more from her than
the rest of the cast She's inexperienced
at leading a comedy so it comes across
as awkward I've never cared that Rob
Zombie casts her in all of his movies in
fact for the two of them I'm sure is
pretty [ __ ] cool to make horror
movies with the person you love and
share your life with it's kind of
romantic in a way but when you switch
gears in switching the genre over to
Comedy both her and Rob Zombie should
have known that she wasn't up to the
task granted she wasn't up to the task
any more than Rob Zombie was up to the
task of making a family comedy but
either of them are or both should have
known that the comedic timings off in
terms of the writing and the editing as
well the costumes oh my God this movie
looked like Spirit Halloween store they
were like hey let's just go into the
dead corpse and the bones of an old Toys
R Us and buy some costumes it looked
like costumes to such a degree that
there's a scene where they're at this
party in this neighborhood this
neighborhood's just having a costume
Rave for some reason I don't know it
seems like it probably was like why
didn't I grow up there but these are
people in costumes and it looks
indistinguishable from the other
costumes previously in the movie that
are supposed to be actual monsters shout
out to Tomas Boykin as Lester first of
all the entire makeup budget went to him
because that's the best makeup in the
movie it has easily not just by a margin
by a clear mile the best screen presence
and the biggest screen presence in this
entire thing and when talking about
movies like this when I'm doing my
videos I like to come at it from
different angles like okay didn't land
for me who's it made for well kids
obviously kind of no it's a rated PG
family comedy it's definitely made for
kids but I don't don't see kids laughing
at the jokes in here kids don't care
about who John Wayne is there's a John
Wayne like they don't care they just
can't help but think if the poor parents
are going to be like oh my God it's on
for the kids and the kids are going to
be like why is my dad watching this in
the end I know Rob Zombie loves the
monsters I mean one of his big hits is
Dragula a reference to the monsters but
this Monster's love letter was more akin
to Freddy Got Fingered where you can
tell Tom Green was like dude I got all
this money for a movie and I'm just
gonna make [ __ ] and the Studio's just
gonna have to deal with the fact that
they gave me this money and that's kind
of funny to me so the movie always came
across to me anyway I feel like Rob
Zombie either did that or this movie's
allegory if not a warning where it's
like if you take all the offensive
comedy out of the world this is the only
kind of Comedy that you're gonna have be
warned maybe that's what he's trying to
say I don't know and I posted a YouTube
short about this movie but the story in
the YouTube short is true it was
midnight I was like oh hey it dropped
and I was watching it I was like this
has been going on forever and I paused
it it was 55 minutes into the movie
which is right around the halfway mark
it's right there which is another gripe
about this movie this movie is way too
long hour and a half Max hours 20
minutes would have been better but I was
like we're 55 minutes in and watching
the rest of the movies another 55
minutes that is the same as pressing
start from the beginning and doing
everything we've already done all over
again that was a horrendous thought so I
just turned it off and went to bed
finished it today so now I get you this
video but it's one of those case and
point things I I felt like it was that
horrible that I went to bed so obviously
sorry Rob Zombie this movie is dog [ __ ]
love Hillbilly Deluxe though all right
so the monsters by Rob Zombie it's on
Netflix now have you seen it what did
you think about it did you see it that's
a real question but if you did curious
to know your thoughts whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]